[Musique]
le
monsieur bonjour je vous interdis
aujourd'hui pour un signe intéressant
même si mme courjault j'aurais j'aurais
voulu avoir votre avis sur le concept de
cyber guerre de sider paix qu'est ce que
vous pouvez me dire là dessus et
je veux commencer là dessus sur on s'est
fait vacciner pendant des années avec ce
concept de cyber guerre qui correspond à
une forme de militarisation de
l'internet déploiement d'infrastructures
on pense au début d'année 6 à la deep
packet inspection des dispositions
législatives pour donner des pouvoirs
offensifs en matière de cyber attaques
maintenant en france à vannes ici et des
institutions dans le monde entier cdc la
commande publique qui part avec des
contrats je ne sais combien de zéros
pour les mêmes entreprises qui vendent
des missiles et des chasseurs le
problème c'est quand on parle de
cyberguerre on parle d'internet comme un
champ de bataille vous parle de mon
groupe on oublie juste un paramètre qui
est le citoyen et pendant des années on
nous a vendu une vision de la sécurité
de la cyber sécurité qui s'appelait
cybergun dans laquelle on oublier les
citoyens et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
les révélations snowden le programme
bull rome 2 qui vise à saboter
activement une par une toutes les
technologies commerciales de protection
de données de communication on
s'aperçoit au générique on a tous un
espion dans la poche est-ce que vous
pouvez un petit peu de développer le
programme lustres leur gueule au delà au
delà des différents programmes de la
nasa on constate l'échec des politiques
de cybersécurité la seule chose à
laquelle ca service et à des contrats
d'un complexe militaro industriel qui va
falloir renault mais je sais pas le
complexe militaro numérique ou quelque
chose comme ça alors que personne n'a
pensé à y développer la cyber pète la
cyber paix se baser sur la définition de
la paix la paix c'est un état dans
lequel on est libre de la peur de
l'agression
qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire dans
l'environnement numérique être libre de
la peur de la délation ça veut dire vrai
le citoyen au coeur de la sécurité ça
veut dire mettre le citoyen au coeur de
la technique ça veut dire rendre le
contrôle de la technologie aux citoyens
eh bien on aspire à des politiques
publiques on serait en termes de cyber
cela plutôt qu'en terme de cyberguerre
vérifie les oreilles si vous pouvez moi
je crois que ce possibilité de cyber
guerre ne soit probablement que là la
plus grosse escroquerie intellectuelle
de ces dernières années quand on est
placé au plan purement opérationnel
je pense que la partie si des roquettes
une dimension supplémentaire à la fin du
xxème siècle comme l'a été la déviation
au début au début du xxème ne jouera
qu'un rôle marginal d'appui vos
préparations sont d'un conflit classique
pour pas oublier que la guerre consiste
à prendre la position de deux raids
auraient été bien matériel qu'ils soient
des territoires
que ce soit des ressources etc sont
aussi les esprits et il faut pas oublier
que la finalité de la guerre c'est
justement de prendre la main sur des
variétés concret donc le cyber mon avis
restera marginale sa tombe est là qu il
faut lé comment s'appelle le le
relativiser et mini jeux d'été c'est une
réalité qui s'impose à nous mais elle
n'a pas l'ampleur tombe bien lui prêter
je suis d'accord que c'est plus pour
légitimer des d'une part des dépenses
pharaoniques dans la manif mais ce jeu
surtout plus qu'une syberia 3 qu'on est
en train de mettre en place des cyber
dictature et pour se développer on
s'aperçoit que programme prisme les
prismes l'un existe à éviter l'effet des
deux antécédents pour savoir ce qui est
quand même une
des principales démocraties
ont tendance à se tourner un état
policier numérique moi ce qui me gêne
dans les évolutions récentes c'est qu'on
remplace la présomption d'innocence par
la présomption de culpabilité quand on
espionne toutes les personnes par défaut
pas seulement des communications
téléphoniques parce que vous avez ce
contact avéré avec les terroristes
corses où les terroristes le monde
islamique
quand on espionne en permanence le
junior vous moindre prix il faut savoir
qu'avec l'internet connectés et
notamment le cp l'outdoor ce manière que
de l'extérieur oppose à ce qui se passe
en quittant votre consommation
électrique et les outils mathématiques
de traitement de l'information le
permettre là quand on espionne en
permanence à de manière aussi intime les
jantes sait qu'on part du principe que
ils sont partout par défaut que par
défaut coupable ou susceptibles de
perfectos et ne pas avoir un état fort
panetta doit être fort mais sans faire
confiance aux citoyens sans les laisser
libres et sans les respecter et si on se
méfie des citoyens à lisbonne spéciaux
de l'état et a fait récemment un
cryptographe belge a annoncé que lui
même était
piraté par la haine et ça coûterait dans
le jargon qu'est ce que vous en pensez
sous peine encore des gens
[Musique]
c'est logique en plus ce qui m'amène
j'ai bien connu pour avoir plus d
activités mathématiques et la manne
senti c'est aussi quelqu'un qui à une
époque n'a pas voulu aller dans le sens
du contrôle de la cryptographie
notamment universitaires par les élus
américains alors tout simplement c'est
quelqu'un qui compte dans de mélanie qui
a une production s'occupe de tout
premier plan
qui a d'ailleurs eu des cas il est pliée
à l'époque puisque savoir qu'il y là lui
il a les faits avec un net recul tant
qu' état français guillou le fameux
protocole qui occupent squatteurs qui a
été pillée par une danseuse américaine
en violation directe des brevets sauf
que trois avocats français contre 50
états américains
la cause a été vite entendue donc c'est
pas étonnant qu'il était questionné mais
encore une fois ce qui m'étonne c'est
qu'on ait encore des gens qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un petit peu sur
la capacité que les gens eux mêmes le
simple particulier à se protéger de ce
genre de de pillage de d'infiltration
dans son système
il ya deux choses distinctes
la surveillance ciblée la surveillance
de masse
j'espère que les prochaines révélations
snowden nous montrerons vu par comment
on peut passer de l'un à l'autre est ce
que le simple fait de ne pas utiliser
facebook google ou apple ne vous met pas
immédiatement dans la catégorie sur les
ans il est prévu d'utiliser des
logiciels libres ou tort et là ça fait
de vous un potentiel terroriste
mais il faut encore distinguer les deux
la surveillance ciblée on le voit avec
les dernières révélations sur les
implants matériels et autres joujoux la
nasa
vous savez déjà on ne peut pas y
échapper
ça c'est une réalité la surveillance
ciblée est légitime lorsqu encadrés par
l'autorité judiciaire
lorsqu'il viendrait trop contrôle
citoyen et démocratique
des actions des services qui la
pratiquent ce qui est véritablement
intolérable c'est la surveillance de
masse
fillol c'est la présomption de
culpabilité
c'est
des violations massives nous nos
libertés individuelles qui ne peuvent en
aucun cas respecter le principe de
proportionnalité
or cette surveillance de masse a priori
on peut y échapper est-ce que vous allez
dans le sens des rides filiol sur la
cyber dictature d'un gouvernement ou des
gouvernements qui commence à avoir peur
de leurs propres concitoyens et qui
commence à monitorer l'ensemble de leur
population c'est manifeste la doctrine
de la msa c'est que l'ennemi se situant
par définition dans le reste du monde on
va espionner le reste du monde comme ça
on aura après coup espionner nos ennemis
c'est une doctrine qui est une forme de
paranoïa d'état et c'est évidemment un
problème ne le fait est que l'on peut
aujourd'hui probablement échappé à cette
surveillance de masse et c'est ça
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est d'augmenter le
coût de cette surveillance ou de tenter
de la rendre inopérante par nos actions
à la différence
des processus classique dans lesquelles
on voyait intervenir le renseignement où
l'armée s'était souvent armés contre
armée et à contres et à la la vaste
majorité des acteurs c'est des citoyens
et
l'ancien troyen vous parlez de citoyens
vous sortez d'une conférence que vous
avez menées à sciences po est ce que
vous avez trouvé les étudiants sensibles
à ce type de nouvelles valeurs de ce
type de menace est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils étaient en retard par rapport à
la perception que la communauté des
hackers on peut la voir sur la
cybersécurité sur les techniques de
surveillance de masse et ce genre de
choses est ce que vous pensez que la
nouvelle génération est prête à résister
ou est prête à trouver les nouveaux
outils pour pouvoir échapper ce type de
surveillance fait ch passe ici une heure
avec une promo d'un master de sciences
po et un échantillon représentatif
une chose dont je suis sûr c'est que sur
les les dix jours qui vient de s'écouler
il ya cinq personnes qui sont venues me
voir en disant ah mais tu sais quoi j'ai
quitté facebook est pour beaucoup ils
vont 10 et suit avec pour la station
qu'on avait vus ensemble dans ces
derniers mois c'est des dizaines de
journalistes que j'ai vu se mettre à eau
terre ou agility pour chiffrer leurs
communications et c'est 100% des
journalistes à qui j'ai parlé de la
protection de leur sauce qui m'ont
répondu ah ouais c'est vrai là on a un
problème eric filiol eric filiol jeanny
pas de chiffrement pour la protection
des sources qu'est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire en tant qu'expert avec votre
qualité des expertises d'un cryptographe
parce que les journalistes sont à l'abri
il est sûr que d'abord signé bien au
clair j'ai conclu que les facultés
j'ai voulu que les choses maintenant il
faut que je crois qu'il faut pas se
voiler la face que la plupart des
standards de chiffrement sont
d'obédience américaine
mais la subtilité américaine a été de
c'est la politique du haut du panier ils
n'ont pas placé toutes les manières
habito moi ce qui me gêne c'est que
l'ensemble de la planète utilisent des
algorithmes de bonheur ce américaine et
uniquement cela
j'ai eu un constructeur que je ne
nommerai pas qui avait fait le choix
d'un christ de chiffrement non
américains et qui quand il a été racheté
par une société américaine a été obligée
de mettre la messe donc le problème
c'est que on laisse aux états unis
le monopole d une idée toute la
standardisation moi je conteste le fait
les américains définissent le standard
crime que je pense qu'il ya de très bons
prix colonnes en france il y en a
partout en europe pourquoi devrait-on
sous traiter notre sécurité et les
standards de chiffres balle
aux amériques est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est un renoncement de l'état
français pas que des défenseurs de
l'ensemble des pays du g8 sauf qu'en
france c'est d'autant plus surprenant
qu'on pas dire scandaleux quand on est
d'une délation prééminente en matière
écrit que le lien donc on à l'école
normale supérieure produits les travaux
extrêmement brillant le problème c'est
que pour une place d'un comité de
programme dans des coqueiros américaine
sous contrôle rien et ça malheureusement
ils font le jeu des états unis nous
avons capacité de réaction nous avec
appétit de résistance nous avons un
génie français ne faut pas l'oublier on
peut pas sous traiter votre sécurité en
tout cas on ne fera jamais de sécurité
si on utilise les méthodes les standards
les outils l'adversaire
j'ai un musée normal voulait rebondir
j'ai fait ce n'est même pas parler
souveraineté à proprement parler parce
que concept d'état nation est parce qu
il c'est facile à manier le plus où nous
définit le plus mais là il ya quelque
chose vraiment flagrant avoir la
souveraineté d'un état tiers
non seulement empiéter sur la
souveraineté d'autres les états mais
aussi sur le sur la souveraineté les
individus sur nos souverainetés
informationnel donc là il ya
manifestement un espace pour des
politiques publiques a tenté d'inverser
cette vapeur là et est le seul moyen de
faire ça j'en suis convaincu c'est de
remettre la technologie aux mains des
citoyens il faut que les citoyens
comprennent l'importance de la vie
privée pour comprendre l'intérêt de la
cryptographie pour comprendre comment
gérer avec le chiffrement elle pourrait
éventuellement être en position de
choisir leur logiciel de chiffrement ou
le choisir leurs algorithmes quand on
génère une léger mais j'ai on peut
choisir entre plusieurs algorithmes et
bien j'ai l'impression qu'il est
essentielle aujourd'hui d'élever le
niveau de conscience mais individus
d'une part et de l'autre qu'il faut des
politiques publiques des politiques
industrielles pour aller favoriser ces
technologies qui ne sont pas aux mains
de la msa qui repose évidemment sur le
logiciel libre les architectures
décentralisée et le chiffrement pour un
point le mot de la fin eric filiol ce
qui me ce qui me fait peur c'est que
l'agglo 95
frustrés les basculer d'un gouvernement
démocratique
mais pas trop quand on met en place les
infrastructures sont en place
potentiellement du moins des petites
surveillance
sadly salaire à nadal mais hadopi vous
permettre à quelqu'un non seulement
savoir compter les contenus et
potentiellement illégales mais de savoir
vous vous intéressez à l'art africain
à la reprise ce qui est prévu
c'est à risque est permanent et j'étais
surpris de voir que la situation se
connaît de la sensibilisation
ce risque est permanent on peut très
bien basculer vers un régime beaucoup
moins démocratique avec des valeurs
nauséabondes jugement de l'actualité
récemment a montré que encore une fois
que vous n'avez pas si lourd et l'extase
ce qui vous fait penser tout ce que l'on
est en face l'accord a été utilisée
légitimement par justement c'est
clairement moins démocratiques s'il veut
les voir
voilà un automatisme j'ai aussi nous
automatique des arrestations en masse et
c'est ça qui me fait peur dans un état
démocratique moi de me faire bien je
viens faire confiance à nos épargnes si
l'agenda 21 des riaux oui tant que c est
un réseau
jérémy l'interview quelque chose bien
sûr quand on parle de protection de la
vie privée on parle d'une liberté plus
fondamental que les autres parce qu'elle
permet l'exercice et des autres libertés
et que cette cette vie privée c'est
avant tout notre nos intimités
d'intimité c'est un espace dans lequel
on n'est pas jugé lors qu'elles ont on
partage la confiance et dans laquelle on
peut expérimenter dans lequel on peut
inventer de nouvelles idées de nouveaux
concepts dans lequel on peut être nous
mêmes cette vie privée cette intimité
c'est nos identités c'est ce qui nous
définit en tant qu'être humain et c'est
ça qui est dangereux je crois au travers
de cet impératif de reprendre le
contrôle de la technologie c'est
reprendre le contrôle de la technologie
pour reprendre le contrôle de notre
humanité
freire se laisser contrôler par la
machine j'allais zimmermann merci des
riffs findel merci
l'analphabétisme aujourd'hui c'est le
quad si vous savez pas coder vous est
analphabète au même titre que les pleins
d'analphabètes au xviiie siècle d'alfred
alfa beta non analphabète heures vous
avez pas coder c'est à peu près aussi
handicapant pour le monde qui arrive
devant vous que de ne pas savoir lire
audi spécial c'est est ce que l'économie
américaine va continuer à une faible
croissance
je dirais que c'est probable et que leur
principal handicap et la finance on ne
peut plus parler du poids de la parole
diplomatique française au moyen orient
elle n'existe plus c'est la parole
américaine c'est ils sont devenus des
porte parole de la parole américaine
[Musique]